بصفتك مستثمرًا ملاكًا ، هل أنت مهتم
بمستقبل الاستثمار في الشركات الناشئة
في ضوء انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ،
لا أشعر بالقلق في حد ذاته لأنني
أعتقد في الواقع
أن ما سنراه يخرج من هذا
هو أموال أقل يتم إلقاؤها على الأشياء
التي  ليست أعمالًا قابلة للحياة
بطريقة غريبة ، فأنا أقل قلقًا ولست مهتمًا أكثر
لأنني أعتقد أن ما يفعله الكثير من المال
والتمويل هو أنه يخفي الكثير من
نقاط الضعف في شركة ناشئة وأن
الكثير من الشركات الناشئة لم تكن كذلك  مبنية على
بناء عمل تجاري فعليًا ولكن من خلال
التحول إلى شركات هندسة مالية ،
كل ما تفعله هو زيادة رأس المال ، لذا
أعتقد أنه برأس مال أقل أو رأس مال أكثر
تكلفة ، فإنه سيجبر
الشركات على أن تكون أعمالًا حقيقية ، ولذا
فأنت تعلم أنني لن أقول إنني  أشعر
بالقلق من أنني في الواقع متفائل بشأن ذلك ،
شكرًا لك